when I watched the Mad King die I
remembered him laughing as your father
burned itself like justice I think that
he's a very honorable man what did the
Mad King say when you stabbed him in the
back he said the same thing he'd been
saying for hours burn them all I like
him because he doesn't make excuses for
himself he does some horrible things
that you can't excuse but he has very
good reason for the things I do for love
you had good reason for doing that
horrible thing in the episode one way
pushes a kid out of the window but it
makes sense if you think about it excuse
it but if that kid told anyone what he'd
seen they would mean the death of woman
he loves and her children himself if it
was your choice your own children or
some stranger you can understand anyway
the Starks are feasting us at sundown
don't leave me alone with these people I
like him I think is he's an interesting
character and I think it's very
honorable I'm looking for my brother you
remember my brother don't you Lord Stark
blond hair sharp tongue short man honors
is honesty and trustworthiness and
loyalty name any honorable man in a war
situation that isn't gonna do anything
you can to get rid of the other of the
enemy I'm going to open your Lord from
balls to brains and see what Starks are
made of is it honorable in the very
first scene of of Game of Thrones where
Ned Stark takes out this kid who's ran
away from from from he's scared to death
he's seen these White Walkers and then
he's but he ran away so this is you he
chopped his head off because that's the
honorable thing to do but in your mind
is that honorable if you know many men I
suppose not women horses didn't mean to
give offense my lady forgive me
what's great about the show it's like it
you know you you you think you have one
truth about a Karass and then you
actually you know a few episodes down
there or you go oh I went ahead with a
man at home and it questions your own
beliefs and I think that's interesting
slip out of that gown and we'll see if
I'm not - I do like a violent woman I
will kill you tonight ser pack your head
in a box and send it to your sister